Quarantine self-isolation and distancing
human beings are social creatures making
life in the time of a pandemic a
challenging and lonely it's just not how
we're built but we are in it together
and among us are people who learn to
live in isolation
long before the corona virus outbreak
how do they prepare and what can we
learn from them hi I'm Janelle de Milan
and in today's kovat 19 special we'll be
talking about how to get through
collective isolation and we've got some
professional insights from some who know
what it's like to be far away from
everyone and everything but first to
someone else in isolation at home our
science correspondent Derek Williams can
life continue normally after quarantines
wouldn't that risk other outbreaks this
is indeed the great danger and it's also
the key question even if strict social
distancing helps us to flatten the
epidemiological curve by by suppressing
the numbers of new infections won't the
number of people getting it just
skyrocket again once we end those
measures are we just kicking the can
down the road a lot of eyes are turning
to China now as it cautiously begins to
lift some of the draconian restrictions
that have been in place there for the
last couple of months everyone is sort
of waiting with bated breath to see
whether the number of new cases there
begins to rise again but there are an
awful lot of experts now saying that
until we come up with an effective
vaccine the new coronavirus is here to
stay at least in the near future to keep
it from overwhelming health systems
we'll all have to get used to social
distancing as the new norm along with
the isolation that that brings yeah I
have been self isolating for about two
weeks now and it came about because they
told us at my son's school that a member
of staff had tested positive for a
covert
on a day when I was feeling a little
under the weather and having cold like
symptoms so so I called our security
management team at DW and we all agreed
that it would be best to stay home but
within days we were all doing it you
know here we are 14 days later and it's
astonishing how fast it's become really
the new norm if you told me even a month
ago that this is where I would be
sitting right now broadcasting from my
living room I would have laughed but I'm
not laughing now I would say that
compared to other places we still have
it pretty easy I think here in Berlin at
least Germany has gone into what's
called lockdown light or at least that's
what people here are calling it which
means that we're we're still allowed to
go out of that home but in general I
think that the biggest challenge for me
so far has been sort of separating my
work time from my leisure time it's
really difficult to work out of your
home I'm discovering much more difficult
than I thought it was going to be
another big issue for me is that there's
only sort of one topic that's being
discussed both professionally and
privately was with my family and with
when I talk to friends on the phone
everybody's only talking about
coronavirus coronavirus coronavirus you
want a little more distraction and you
want a wider range of topics that's
really kind of a big challenge that's
kind of the million-dollar question
isn't it I kind of I hate to say it but
I've talked to quite a few experts who
are kind of predicting that this is
going to go on for months at least I
think it depends a lot on how the virus
reacts to environmental changes as a
spring rise and summer arrives and as it
gets warmer here we still don't really
know how it's going to react to those
different climatic conditions we're
still a very very long way from turning
the corner on this disease
now there's being stuck at home but
arguably there are tougher places to be
alone
astronaut Matthias Mauer has been
training for years for his future flight
into space and isolation this Matthias
the mission scientist and this is my log
foundation day to cut off from the
outside world with little equipment and
even fewer comforts Matthias Maurer
spent six days in the darkness of this
cave in Italy to help them prepare for
the rigors of space he learned how to
explore unknown surroundings and how to
conduct scientific experiments
underground and Mateus Maura joins us
now Mateus welcome you're also having to
stay home these days how's your
astronaut training helped at all yes I
feel I'm quite prepared for the
isolation I mean I lived in a cave for
several days I lived also underwater for
16 days in a very tiny confined
environment with other people and we got
pretty well along each other well what
would you say the hardest part was then
was it communication was it the cabin
fever or in your case the cave fever or
something else completely
well it's living together with other
people like in a confined environment
for an extended period of time and for
astronauts it's even it is bit more
complicated because once we're in space
we will lift there for six months we all
come from different countries different
languages have a cultural background
which is different and so communication
is the key and we learn before we fly to
space how to how to like adapt our way
how to interact with others so we talk
very openly on the problems that this
needs like okay you have this and this
which I don't really like can you change
this manner a little bit and then once
you talk openly then you feel well
prepared and then I think that the
mission itself is then very easy well
what would you say helped you
psychologically speaking while you were
disconnected from everything
well it's very important to have a
regular schedule during the day so I
plan my day and I plan a project I plan
also positive parts that I have during
today and then we also plan to have time
together together with my crew together
with my team and it's lunchtime it's
evening dinner time it's very important
to spend this time together we also
included a little bit of physical
exercise despite being in a very
confined environment but you still can
do some exercises and this combination
of having a schedule of having a project
of having friends together with you that
helped you that cheer you up I think
that was also very important and we have
a successful mission
there you have it structure is key
Mattias Maurer he's an astronaut from
the European Space Agency thank you so
much for sharing your insights my
pleasure now as we heard there not
everyone is distancing alone there are
those who have to do it in groups being
with the same set of people all the time
can obviously be hard perhaps even
impossible without a bit of fun but
don't take our word for it the crew on
the International Space Station can tell
you more she knows what it feels like to
be up there alone u.s. astronaut
Christina cook repairing the outside of
the International Space Station last
year she set a record by spending 328
days in space in the ISS you literally
couldn't get any further from the
coronavirus but the astronauts on board
have a lot in common with the millions
in isolation 400 kilometers away back on
earth constantly packed in together yet
separated from any other life unable to
visit family and friends for months
that's why crew were trained to deal
with the psychological impact of living
in space keeping busy is the key whether
working getting a haircut
or of course having a restful night's
sleep the ISS crew like Christina know
all too well how to stay healthy and
happy in isolation
Jack's toaster is an isolation
researcher and a cultural anthropologist
specializing in the measurement and
enhancement of human performance and
extreme environments well that's a
mouthful there you've done a lot of work
with astronauts you've been advising
NASA for several decades what sort of
advice have you given two astronauts
giving up a way of life on earth to go
to space seeing us that can be helpful
now well most astronauts determined
before their mission that getting along
with their crewmates
will be their highest objective and they
work toward that goal ways to foster the
group solidarity that's necessary when
things become a problem or to work to a
schedule as mattias ed just said it but
it is okay to sleep in not on the
International Space Station but when
you're confined in your homes sleep is
good just make sure that you have a
schedule and that you make a list of
objectives and I think the the key to
surviving I'm in our twelfth day of
isolation now but the key is to view
this as an opportunity rather than an
obstacle an opportunity to to finish
projects that you had let slide around
the house an opportunity to read a book
that you'd always wanted to read an
opportunity to call friends and family
and talk for as long as you would like
and to check in on their physical and
behavioral health so I guess in some way
it is a matter of reframing but there's
knowing you'd be isolated for a limited
time like on a space mission versus now
where nobody knows how long they'll have
to stay home for how does one deal with
the open endedness perhaps of this
isolation yes that it that is the
difficult part this is imposed on us we
didn't volunteer for this space mission
but we are indeed passengers on a
spacecraft
passing through space and time together
and some of the ways that we can make
this work is to consciously attempt to
be polite and respectful with those with
whom were confined to avoid derisive
humor the kind of humor that establishes
wedges between people humor is fine it
is an excellent coping mechanism but
avoid the decide the derisive humor that
is so common especially among men
consider the possible consequences
before you say or do anything
consciously attempt to be cheerful and
supportive of your housemates or your
crewmates and eat at least one meal
together
each day the importance of kindness are
there again and the importance of
avoiding the use of humor but speak of
social skills that we all have to assume
that the outbreak will one day be under
control and we'll all be reconnecting
based on what you know about astronauts
coming back how do you think we will
have changed as a people after all of
this well astronauts spend a lot of time
in the cupola watching the beautiful
earth passed beneath them and almost all
of them report when they return that
they have changed it that that
experience has changed their perspective
of life on earth there are no borders
really visible from space and during the
early days of the space of the ISS space
station there would be an American
fighter pilot teamed with a former
Soviet fighter pilot they had trained
their entire careers to kill each other
and yet they got along famously they
lived in perfect harmony and working
toward the same goals and I think that
that's the kind of thing that we can
derive from this experience we're all
working towards the same goals a
reminder from Jax to sir he's an
isolation
researcher and longtime advisor to NASA
thank you very much and that was our DW
Cova 19 special for more do check out
our social media channels I'm Janelle de
millau and we'll leave you now with
music from opera singers seeing together
from Greece but alone in their own homes
thank you for watching and stay healthy
everyone
[Music]